OPERATORS OF THE COLONIAL
PIPELINE ARE WARNING THAT THEY
MAY NOT RETURN TO FULL SERVICE
FOR SEVERAL MORE DAYS.
GAS STATIONS THROUGHOUT
SOUTHEAST ARE RUNNING DRY.
THIS COMES AS THE WHITE HOUSE
ADMITS THERE IS A GAS SHORTAGE
AFTER ALL AFTER DOWNPLAYING THE
CRISIS EARLIER THIS WEEK.
>> THE TWO RESPONSES FROM THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS SPOKESPERSON
ARE UNNERVING.
THEY ARE NAÏVE AND WEEK.
AND DON'T SHOW AN UNDERSTANDING
OF THE PROBLEM.
>> YESTERDAY BEFORE HE CAME ON
THE AIR THE PRESIDENT SAID YOU
ARE GOING TO BE HEARING GOOD
NEWS SOON ABOUT THE PIPELINES.
THEY ARE EVENTUALLY GOING TO GET
BACK ONLINE THEY PAID HACKERS
$5 MILLION SO THEY PAID THE
RANSOM.
THEY PAID THE RANSOM AND THE
PRESIDENT MUST HAVE KNOWN ABOUT
THIS.
THAT'S A VERY COMPLICATED ANSWER
TO A HOSTAGE SITUATION.
I KNOW 45% OF THE OIL AND GAS
JET FUEL IS AFFECTED.
BUT THEY PAID THE RANSOM AND
THEY SAID THE ENCRYPTION IS SO
SLOW THAT THEY ARE STILL DOING
THIS MANUALLY.
YOU TOOK THE ENTIRE EAST COAST
TO ITS KNEES.
CAN YOU IMAGINE WHAT ELSE IS
SUSCEPTIBLE A PRIVATE COMPANY
THAT AFFECTS US SO SUBSTANTIALLY
WE HAVE TO REVISIT ALL OF THESE
THINGS.
WITH GAS GOING UP TO AROUN